so let me ask you a question what if you
could experience more freedom and more
money
on youtube at the same time
in this very video you're going to be
learning how to work with virtual staff
and buy more time how to become more
productive and how to build your dream
business i've learned that one is too
small a number to achieve greatness and
so in this video chris ducker is going
to be breaking down how to hire your
first person to help you with your
youtube channel how do you hire a video
editor a virtual assistant or what
positions do you need to hire for in
terms of really building a real business
around your social media influence in
your personal brand
and why hire in this very training
you're going to be learning that hiring
is so important so that you don't burn
out so that you can focus on what you're
good at and maybe delegate the things
that you don't love or that are
frustrating to you because that's not
your gift you're going to learn also how
to make a bigger impact by building even
a small team and also how you can get
everything done because let me know in
the comments if you already feel like
man i got a lot to do my to-do list is
longer than my time list and so i do
need help
with this in just a second we're going
to welcome chris ducker on but if you're
just meeting him he's a serial
entrepreneur family man action taker
lover of fine whiskey the blues and
luxury travel and he's been helping
entrepreneurs literally change the world
he's the founder of virtual staff finder
and youpreneur and he's wrote a couple
best-selling books that have crushed it
the rise of the youtube uh the rise of
the youpreneur and also virtual freedom
which is the very topic of this training
of course i want to encourage you
there's resources in the show notes and
in the description down below so you can
get access to all of chris's content but
with that can we welcome chris ducker to
the stream today
chris how you doing hey hey how are you
man
so good to see you hey where are you
streaming from right now
i'm right here in my home studio my home
office here in cambridge england
cambridge england man well i'm coming to
you from seattle washington and i'm so
fired up you should give it away right
here
this this little this little union jack
should give it away
is that a uh is that a refrigerator
it is or is that luggage well actually
it's a cooling box
so it can keep you know cans or bottles
of water and things like that cool but
uh you're not gonna get any ice out of
it put it that way
man i love it well i'm so fired up for
the training today we already shared a
little bit about you you'll probably
share a little bit about your story as
well so chris i'm fired up i'm ready to
take notes uh take it away
rock and roll well it's great to be with
you all uh i appreciate sean the think
team for having me um genuinely
this is a topic that i hold very very
close to my heart
um it's a topic that i never tire of
talking about or sharing or training
people on and i hope genuinely that you
get a lot out of our time
uh with each other today before i go any
further go ahead and drop a
free resource to you towards the end of
it i'm going to give you the link
towards the end of our time about 30
minutes or so from now um so make sure
that you uh pay attention for that at
the end of the presentation
so here's a quick set of questions for
you do any of these sound like you
currently and if you are watching live
please go ahead and record i've got the
comments on my screen i can see what's
going on here as well so number one
do you consistently wish that there was
more time in the day
are you left frustrated at the end of
your work day because you haven't ticked
everything on your to-do list off if
that's you let me know
are you pushing back
projects
that you'd love to get stuck into
because you just simply don't have
enough time i know that i used to do
that pretty much on a daily basis so are
you doing any of these things
do any of these
titles make up what you do
as an entrepreneur are you a coach or a
speaker or a video marketer or a course
creator or an author
or a podcaster are you doing all these
things if you are
then genuinely
i get it i get it completely i'm just
like you
myself i'm a serial entrepreneur i'm a
podcaster i'm a video guy i do all those
things too but ultimately just another
hard-working entrepreneur that is on a
journey to genuinely help and serve as
many people as i possibly can
and if i get the opportunity to be able
to meet some of those people through
friends like sean and the rest of the
guys at think media then it makes my
life a lot easier in doing so i blog and
podcast over at chrisducker.com
i video
pretty much on a weekly basis over on
youtube i had gap i've got that
best-selling book virtual freedom over
100 000 copies sold in seven languages
now
i like to coach folks as much as i
possibly can through our youtube
incubator and i hold our annual
conference in london every single year
uh the youpreneur summit as well now
some of you might have read virtual
freedom some of you maybe have never
heard of me or that book ever before uh
and that's absolutely fine doesn't dent
my ego in any way whatsoever however i
want to make it very very clear to you
that i'm not your typical online
business owner in fact actually i've
been running and growing businesses
almost 18 years now i have different
businesses that are making up the group
of companies that i own live to sell is
a large call center facility in the
philippines we have virtual staff finder
which is basically match.com
for filipino virtual assistants who are
experienced and hardworking and
folks that are just like yourselves
probably and uh you know stressed out a
little uh overworked shall we say and
then we've got youpreneur which is all
about our personal branding and expert
based businesses but virtual staff
finder was established in august of 2010
and since then we've hit a whole bunch
of people in fact actually we've helped
over 8 000 people find va's over in the
philippines to help them run support and
grow their business
so today's call if you are feeling a
little burnt out if you are wanting to
scale faster if you are wanting to have
more impact with the work that you're
doing and putting out into the world
it's a lot easier to do that when you've
got people helping you out and this is
why today's training is so very
important it's important because we're
going to go through the dangers of
entrepreneurial burnout and more
importantly how this can help you avoid
it we're going to talk about the
different types of outsourcing and
virtual staffing that are available to
you
and
where you can find vas and how you can
go ahead and hire them the right way to
get started with working with your
virtual team we're going to be talking
about the best way to onboard and train
your virtual assistants as well as the
two biggest mistakes that entrepreneurs
make when it comes to working with
remote employees and then we're going to
cap off looking at the best tools that
you should use when working with your
virtual staff to minimize the work that
they're doing for you so that you can
maximize that return on the investment
now this all sounds great and everything
but i want to make it clear i wasn't
always
this
smooth when it comes to running my
business in fact actually as sean
alluded to in the intro there in 2009
i've been running my business for a
while and i actually hit burnout one day
i fundamentally couldn't get out of bed
i was absolutely exhausted my wife
called a family doctor he came around
got me straight into the hospital had a
load of tests done and i was diagnosed
with acute dehydration and acute
exhaustion and mild depression i was put
on a course of antidepressants for a
period of time i was in hospital for
several several days connected to an iv
because i'd been doing nothing but
drinking a ton of you know coffee all
the time and trying to stay awake and
build my business and not only did that
burn out hit me then
but i also got another kick up the
backside attach that back that burnout
2012 when i had to have an l5 s1 spinal
fusion
done
to be able to fix a problem that had
come about of me fundamentally
crushing my lower disk as i sat in a
chair for 16 hours a day building my
business
here's the issue that hustle and grind
mentality that so many people talk about
although yes we'll get you success is
ultimately in my opinion
killing a generation of entrepreneurs
it's happening slowly but surely
now
when i started putting together the
content for that book virtual freedom in
2014
that was when i came up with this term
superhero syndrome and basically it
means that you are a typical taipei
micromanaging entrepreneur now i was
that typical taipei micromanaging
entrepreneur i was wearing several
different hats
and throughout the course of 2010
as i was recovering from that burnout
with one major goal which was to become
a virtual ceo and not have to be sitting
in the office every single day with 350
staff around me
i actually ended up hiring eight people
in 2010 to replace me so i was wearing a
lot of different hats the chances are
you're probably wearing a lot of
different hats as well even if you're at
the beginning of your business journey
as a creator and as an entrepreneur
online the chances are you're spinning a
whole bunch of different plates right
now see i
truly honestly truly honestly believe
that we will get to a fork in the road
at some point
where we will have to make a choice
between burning out because it is going
to hit you it's not a matter of if it's
going to hit you it's just a matter of
when and ultimately building a team
getting smart delegating getting things
off your plate so that you can be in
yours of genius and that's what we
should be doing as entrepreneurs we
should only be doing the things that we
know
only we can do
right
so very important to understand that the
difference between those who do really
really well when it comes to building a
business and those that kind of just you
know fly by the wayside ultimately
is the delegation mindset and that's
what we want to do above and beyond
anything else
all of these different tasks that we're
doing on a daily basis
many many of you are probably doing this
right now everything from managing your
schedules to editing your videos to
doing all of your uploading your social
media creating landing pages delivering
your content email newsletter writing
all these different things that you're
doing
to help build your youtube channel to
help build your archive of content to be
found by people that you want to attract
into your ecosystem almost all of these
things
can be
outsourced to a virtual assistant almost
all of them now though i say almost
because there are a number of things
that only you
should be doing like being in front of
the camera for a start right like you're
the star you're the one with the
expertise and the passion so you need to
be front and center in your business but
editing that video
you shouldn't be doing that
not really not long term
promoting those videos on social media
with images that you create no you
shouldn't be doing that either so we're
going to get into how you can stop doing
that and get into more of a delegation
set we're going to start off with our
three main ways to get started
first up it's task based outsourcing
this is when you've done tasks that you
need done you find somebody to do that
task
they do it they get paid you get what it
is that you've paid for and it's game
over thank you very much for playing so
let's say you've got five different
videos that you want to have transcribed
so you can turn the content in those
videos into an ebook so that you can use
it as an opt-in magnet so that you can
grow your email list well once those
five videos are being transcribed by
that va that job is done and finished
and you've paid them for the task and
you've moved on so that's the first way
to be able to do is via task based
outsourcing
the second way is via projects and much
like the first one this has a finite
timeline involved the uh example i like
to use in this particular situation is
the idea of coming up with a brand new
website or redeveloping your new your
current website right so it's a project
it's not a task it's a project you're
going to need a graphic designer or a
web designer you're going to need a
developer to help code the website to
make sure it doesn't break you're also
going to need maybe a copywriter if
you've got sales pages for your courses
and your products and services your
merchandise and all that sort of stuff
as well but once those people have done
all their work individually collectively
then the project is ticked off they all
get paid it's game over again and that's
the end of it thank you for playing
however there's one more way that i want
to share with you and this is my
favorite way and that is
role based outsourcing this is the gold
standard this
is ultimately what will get you from
where you are right now
to where you want to go and if you think
about it logically
what's got you to the point right now as
to where you are and hey we're all on
different journeys right so you
shouldn't compare your eighth or your
ninth step to somebody else's 80th or
90th right there's no imposter syndrome
allowed here but if you're if you're
here
if you want to get up here you've got to
do something different if you carry on
doing the things that you're doing
that's got you here
you won't go anywhere you'll stay right
here but if you start developing that
delegation mindset and start palming off
tasks and projects to people on a
regular basis to do for you that's when
it becomes really really really exciting
you see
we're visionaries right and as the
entrepreneurial visionaries that we are
we need to hire for the role
and not for
the task let me say that again we've got
to be hiring for the role and not for
the task
all here is not about
just getting rid of one task or one
project it's about building a team
if you build a team of people all in
very specific roles everything becomes
so much easier for you personally and
when it comes to the virtual team it
kicks off with one particular and that
is the general
va or the gva which is a term that i
coined many many years ago now that
general va will be able to handle your
schedule upload your videos do your
social media put together images inside
a canva for you and a host of other
stuff for you on a regular basis as well
however it's just the beginning of the
team
next up we've got our seo or web
marketers to make sure that you're found
in the right places by the right people
at the right time
then you've got content writers and
copywriters that can ultimately come on
board to help you continue to build and
grow your business
then you've got things like mobile app
developers that might potentially come
into your business as and when the need
is put in front of you
from there you've got audio and video
editors that will help you obviously
create the content that you're putting
out into the world so many of you within
the think media community are all about
video
for obvious reasons there are ample
amounts of incredible virtual assistants
out there that can do everything from
very simple slice and dice jump cut edit
stuff right the way down to more um you
know professional b-roll and all this
other sort of stuff right so whatever it
is that you're struggling with right now
and by the way if you're not a video
editor you shouldn't be editing your
videos i often say like if if you're not
a graphic designer then you shouldn't be
designing a logo right you wouldn't have
a plumber in your house
to fix your electrics and therefore we
want to make sure that we've got the
right people in the right roles
following on from audio and video
editors we then got graphic designers
that can come on board and help you from
a visual perspective in building your
brand and your business and then finally
that web developer somebody who's going
to make sure that your business isn't
going to break online and that when
people visit your website they can opt
in properly
right that they can buy your products
properly and that they can ultimately
make all of the changes in their lives
by finding you
properly as well now this
is that interactive type of virtual
dream team as i call it
however
things have changed a lot over the last
five years and i've been in the
outsourcing business for
three times that long 15 years um and i
can honestly say to you things have
changed very very quickly over the last
four to five years or so we have see
other developing roles that have come
out in recent years such as those
youtube management and that goes way
beyond just uploading your video that's
making sure that your videos are found
that they're suggested that they're
linked to that they're talked about
right sales copywriters email funnel
experts facebook ad managers all these
types of roles have come up in recent
years and yes they are all
out there the good news is actually
everywhere
they are literally all around the world
in a number of different places in a
number of different countries in a
number of different territories
and the really good actually for us as
entrepreneurs is that we are no longer
pushed down and held back
by geographical constraints when it
comes to finding the right people for
the right roles you know it used to be
that you'd want someone to come into an
office or at least be in the same state
or the same city that you're working in
but the fact of the matter is the world
doesn't work like that anymore and in
fact over the last 18 months everybody
has realized that this is actually not a
bad way to go when it comes to building
a business being remote being less you
know kind of in each other's faces all
the time and allowing your staff to get
on with whatever they've been delegated
whatever projects they're working on so
that you can stay in your
zone of genius rather for the you know
the genius that you are and the people
that you're serving right
and here's the thing
when it comes to hiring folks it doesn't
need to be
complicated
here are the three components of a
really really good
virtual
hire okay number one is the skill set
now i know
this is a little bit obvious right like
yes they're gonna have to be skilled at
what they're doing but what i say when i
mean skill set is that they've got a
really know what they're doing they've
got to have experience under their belt
doing the exact role
that you are hiring them to do
okay this is one of the biggest mistakes
that people make is that they think oh
they've done these other things i'm sure
they'll be able to do this no if you
want to better hit the ground running
with virtual staff you need to make sure
that you are hiring people
that have already done what you need
done for other people so far if you
don't do that then what you're gonna
have to do is train them up from scratch
yourself or get somebody else in to do
it for you either way you're not gonna
be able to hit the ground running and
you should be able to do that so that's
the first thing is skill set the second
thing is that they've got to have a
driven personality a driven mindset
right they've got to be a driven
person
one of the things i do when i'm
interviewing folks and yes obviously i
have a team in place to do a lot of the
early stage interviews now whenever
we're scaling or bringing somebody on
but the fact is i will never ever ever
interview a prospective member of staff
without asking them a very simple
question and that is this
what do you know about me
and my company
if they can't answer that question then
that shows that they are zero prepared
when it comes to wanting to get a job
with me and my company and if they're
not prepared if they haven't even spent
two seconds
going ahead
genuinely and just googling me and my
business to find out a little bit more
about me then clearly they're not going
to be a very good candidate for the job
so that's the second thing they've got
to go ahead and have the right mindset
finally
they've got to have the right
personality
as well
genuinely they've got to have the right
personality
now i don't know
that they've got to be perfect in every
way let's face it i mean none of us are
perfect but if you're the type of person
who is quite fun-loving who appreciates
family time who appreciates not working
12 14 15 hours a day then the people
that you hire and bring on board have
also got to be relatively fun loving
family orientated
and want to have to do their job you
know those eight hours or so every day
and then take the rest of the time off
if you if you're quirky uh and and you
know
enjoy other people's you know uh
presence and other you know being around
other people like you want people that
are hired like that
if you are brash and in your face and a
little bit more blatant then maybe you
need to be hiring people with those
types of personalities as well bottom
line though that is the three stages of
fire right
skill set
got to be driven
got to have the right personality
now the one thing that a lot of people
skip on when it comes to bringing
somebody on board is training and i want
to touch on this very very seriously
just for a minute the training cannot
and should not be
underestimated when you're talking about
bringing on board a new member of staff
and i don't care whether they're right
next to you in the same room sitting at
the same desk or on the other side of
the world you've got to train people up
number one you got to do it it genuinely
separates the winners from the losers
every single time number two you've got
to make zero
assumptions on this subject as well when
it comes to training you can't assume
anything at all just because they do
have the skill set just because they do
have the right mindset just because they
are the right type of person for your
company and your vibe it doesn't mean
that they know how you want things done
right so you've got to bring them on
board
and make sure that you give them that
foot up that they need right gate
and obviously
clearly when it comes to training and
building a team it pays to develop
training material
once
so that you can do it over
and over
and over again
does this
make
sense
does this make sense
i think it probably does to all of you
so let's go real quick over the va
training trifecta now there are three
ways
that i've identified or work the best
when it comes to working and training
and even actually just delegating on an
ongoing basis with virtual staff members
okay so let's break it down first up
we've got written types of training so
this is the type of stuff that you pop
in an email maybe it's a bullet point
list maybe it's in a project management
system like slack or base camp possibly
you're using messenger apps like
facebook messenger or whatsapp whatever
the case may be
using written instructions to be able to
get across to your va is exactly how you
want something down so that's part one
of the trifecta part two
is
audio training
so anything from quick voice recordings
that you might make um you know when
you're maybe in a hotel room or when
you're traveling you know you're in
departure lounges whatever the case
maybe you're fight you know you're
you're uh sharing files that you've
already pre-recorded at some point
possibly you're doing skype or zoom
calls does anybody use skype
anymore i'm not sure but maybe you're
doing skype or zoom calls um and that's
a great way to be able to record those
calls and have that information that
training on call for as and when you
need it but by far for me personally the
number one most easiest
and most incredible way to be able to
teach
your va's the most useful way to be able
to teach your va's is via
video
okay via
video so anything like zoom video sorry
zoom yeah zoom loom video recordings
screen captures if you're on mac that
means maybe you're using um a uh
what is the big one um screenflow maybe
on camtasia you're on pc whatever the
case may be picture this let's just say
for argument's sake you're putting
together a video that you want to upload
onto youtube now the video is done okay
it's already edited it's already been
exported it's ready to go up to youtube
so what you do is you click record on
your screen capture software and you
start the process of getting that video
up live onto youtube for your public
subscribers and viewers
and fans to consume so first up you've
got to upload the video right so you
upload the video in your usual fashion
then you write out the title then you
write out the description then you pick
your tags then you upload or you choose
your thumbnail then you you know you put
it into a playlist you do all the things
that you do on the back end of youtuber
creator studio to make sure that video
when it goes out whether it's been
scheduled or you're going to publish it
straight away it goes out exactly the
way you want it to happen
when you're done with the process and by
the way all the time as you're doing it
on the screen
you're talking through it audibly as
well
when you're done with that
you hit the
the stop button on the recording you
export that video and you dump it into
dropbox you've now got video number one
in what will become an ever-growing
encyclopedia of va training right there
in dropbox for anybody to watch as many
times as they want so they can consume
your training and understand exactly
what it is that you want them to do and
here's a great thing about this above
and beyond everything else you only ever
ever
have to do this one time because even if
va that initially
was being trained in that particular
task even if that va moves on or you ask
them to move on whatever the case may be
the video is still there for the new
va or maybe another team member might
come in to be able to help out through
holiday seasons or whatever right it's
there all the time for people to consume
over and over again you do it once
you never have to do it again
it's pretty good right
so that's your va
training trifecta and i can see in the
comments that you guys are loving this
stuff that's what it's all about i want
to talk real quick
about communication before we wrap up
with a little exercise with each other
here
communication really honestly is
the magic pill
right like if i go
a couple of weeks without conversing
with my team properly
as great as they are
i know that projects will slow down a
little bit they will i'm the leader
right i'm the guy that
puts things in action and therefore i
should be the guy who communicates with
my team on a regular basis might not
necessarily be daily or hourly possibly
weekly or bi-weekly and definitely
having big meetings on a monthly basis
with our sales team with our finance
team etc etc
but communication is absolutely
everything particularly when you are
with a distance between you right like
if you don't have the ability to be able
to bring somebody into a conference room
facility or your office facility or even
into your home if you work from home if
you don't have
the ability to bring people in person
communication becomes even more
important but what i want to go through
right here is three sets of golden types
of tools that you need to be able to
incorporate to make sure that when you
bring va's on board or continue to grow
your current virtual team
that you do it properly and that
communication
genuinely
is something you think about all the
time
the first set of tools
is project management so whether you're
using basecamp which i talked about a
second ago or something like asana or
monday
or any other form of project management
system or software whatever it is
make sure that everybody in the team has
access sure you might restrict certain
members from seeing certain things but
get everybody in there all on one page
and at least one or two of those
channels right so
that's number one communication
tools
two
the second set of tools is
simple day-to-day communication stuff
now i quit a little bit joked a little
bit about people not using skype anymore
there's still plenty of people using
skype but skype is one of them that you
can search who's workplace by facebook
actually i know many people that use
this they swear by it we at virtual star
finder are all about slack i will slack
for me personally
kind of killed email for me
to a certain degree
i spend
probably no less than half an hour a day
in my inbox now whereas before i would
probably be spending six hours a day in
that inbox managing things right so
slack is a great data communication tool
if you don't use it i genuinely think
that you should go ahead and check it
out and then lastly that's just simple
marketing tools right wordpress for our
blogs
youtube for our videos and maybe
something like captivate which is a
podcast hosting an analytics software
company i am an investor and advisor in
libsyn is you know another one that you
can use as a whole host of them out
there but using these three sets of
on a daily basis or an ongoing basis at
least with your va's will help you to
get not only more productivity
about
uh out of them but also
more opportunity for you to be able to
hit
uh you know the right types of um
prospects they come your way the thing
is like we work so hard can i get real
for a minute we work so hard to build
our brands to build our businesses
to create the content that we create
if we don't work equally if not harder
on the marketing of that content working
with our team in the right professional
manner then honestly what we're doing is
leaving on the table at the end of the
day
fact
so we're going to wrap up our time
together here with
a little exercise with each other and
this is actually an exercise that i
created all those years ago back in 2010
i didn't realize it at the time
but
this particular exercise
changed my life sincerely and i know for
a fact that it's changed thousands of
other people's lives since and that is
three lists to freedom
exercise these three lists ultimately
changed my life and we're gonna
start
working
on this right now together and then what
i want you to do is um you know whether
you're live or or watching the replay
start working on this with me right now
uh but but more importantly
carry on doing it when we're done with
the training when we're done with the
call because i think that all of these
lists need some proper thought process
right you can't just rush through them
so list number one is a list of all the
things that you hate
doing
right
that you hate
doing so things that you procrastinate
on day long you know what i'm like like
the the the dragon drop
procrastination
motion that we all have with managing
our digital cameras right
things that you hate doing the stuff
that you really despise if you are live
actually i'd love for you to just let me
know one thing that you have to do if
not daily at least weekly that you
really just despise doing but you've got
to do it because
your business demands that you do it let
me know in the in the chat no matter
where you're watching i'd love to know
for sure
let's have a look real quick
we've got quickbooks reconciling yep big
one creating engaging youtube titles yep
uh cleaning the house
you should hire a housekeeper that's an
easy one i can't help you with the
housekeepers i'm afraid um copywriting
sending emails editing videos
uh phone calls editing videos again tick
tock live living good lord we don't want
that to happen please feel better soon
uh emails again email again email again
social media posts social media again
okay good stuff so they're all the
things that we absolutely hate
doing
the second list is a list of all the
things that you can't do
okay list of all the things that you
can't do now understand
as a taipei
individual
business owner
entrepreneur
i feel like i can pretty much put my
hand at anything the chances are you
feel exactly the same way however the
fact of the matter is that
we can't do everything there are people
out there that can do a whole bunch of
stuff that we're struggling with a lot
better than us
trust me
trust me on this right which is why i
hired those eight people in the course
of one year to be able to get into that
virtual ceo role and not have to be in
the office every single day so let me
know in the chat
what are the things that you struggle
with the things you can't do that you're
still having to manage yourself
planning videos
archiving and backups
uh
second list is hard to admit to if you
think that's hard wait for the third
list
pc audio software always causes trouble
and i constantly have to fix it yeah
that might
mean you've got to upgrade to a mac just
putting it out there once you go mac you
never go back as they say
buy better gear final cut pro
i could do video editing but i don't
want to there you go so these are the
things you want to start getting out
off of your plate right and then our
third and our final list here is by far
the most important one and this is the
one honestly that you do need to do a
little bit of thinking about
and that is the things that you feel you
shouldn't
actually
be
doing
let me say that again the third list for
the three list of freedom
is jotting down a list of all the things
that as the business owner that you
either are or want to be
[Music]
shouldn't actually be
doing right like your time is much
better spent
being in your zone of genius creating
content
spending more time with you know that
top 20 clientele that you've got
attending conferences widening your
network connecting with smart folks
maybe becoming a member of a mastermind
to grow your business and scale in a
smarter way
maybe it's creating more products and
services or maybe actually you just want
to work
less
and there's nothing wrong with that
maybe you gotta you want to spend more
time with your family or whatever it is
i haven't worked a friday for almost
seven years except for the one or two
every now and then when we've got live
events that we run and my goal actually
by the end of this year
is to slip down to three days a week
before i semi-retire in a couple of
years from now and go to just two days a
week i could never completely retire
like all out it would drive me
absolutely crazy right so those are our
three
to freedom things you hate doing number
one things you can't do or you struggle
doing number two and things that you
shouldn't
actually be
doing now before i wrap up and i'll give
you that link to that resource i
promised let me ask real quick if you're
watching live or
if you check this out on the replay
please let me know in the comments right
this second
what was the most useful thing that you
learned with our time together today
what was the most useful thing maybe it
was that one big aha moment when you
were like oh my gosh
he's talking you know i'm picking up
what he's putting down he's talking my
language what is it i'm curious to know
comparing my business to other
businesses anthony you got to stop doing
that right now brother
because it's 100 unique it's different
to everybody else's business because
you're running it right don't compare
yeah that whole um imposter syndrome
thing will that that's that's a that's a
big one
uh aha moments let's go procrastinate
because i know
i want to have things perfect yeah done
is always better than perfect we know
this right be accountable to yourself
yep most useful thing was creating the
training materials one time to use over
and over again yes wendy you're right uh
how to hire a fia in general how to deal
with burnout yep do the training once
high for the role never assume that they
should know anything
indeed absolutely
so
like i said at the beginning i promised
you that a free resource and i want to
make sure that i uh get that to you plus
there's other useful links for you as
well
so
virtualfreedombook.com to go pick up a
copy of my best-selling book over a
hundred thousand copies a thousand five
star reviews on amazon go check it out
right now
101 tasks to delegate to virtual staff
is a free three or four page pdf
document i can't remember how many pages
to be honest with you but you can check
that out over on our youpreneur site
youpreneur.com
101
tasks
i'm sure that all of these will be
linked below videos everywhere as well
and obviously if you want any help at
all in finding an incredible virtual
assistant over in the philippines
the link is virtual staff finder dot com
on the screen however i would love for
you to use storm's affiliate link which
is think
virtual staff dot com uh because he's
got a child now
okay and he needs money
all right if you're a parent you know
what i'm talking about use his affiliate
link think virtual staff dot com go
check them out there's a salary guide
over there that you can download for
free as well to find out what you should
be paying your va's and a whole host of
other bits and pieces as well that is
the end of my presentation sean
thank you for having me man
man chris that was absolutely incredible
and thank you so much for adding so much
value we have a few more minutes with
chris and so um i'm gonna have him back
on in just a second uh but a couple
things
um number one
what is your big vision for your
business what i loved about chris that
hit me and keep sharing your aha moments
um was he said i haven't worked a friday
besides events in seven years and i'm
thinking about when i can get to three
days and then all the way down to two
days because i'm the same i could never
fully retire i believe we were created
for purpose and impact
but chris is a family man and i just
entered the family season but that spoke
to me was vision
i might not be ready to go there now i'm
in a season of course we have team but
through leadership or through the
momentum or through the building of our
company but what's your vision for the
future when you've got that target that
you're working towards it can help
sustain you
in your present challenges right when
you're facing those frustrating times
and what i love about everything that
chris just shared was this training
is absolutely critical for reaching any
kind of vision of significance in
business
one is too small of a number for
greatness you got to build a team if
you're going to have the family and the
lifestyle and the recurring revenue and
the security can i get real meaning and
the
and the and being set up for the unknown
what happens if something happens to
your health
what happens if something happens
in your personal life in fact
life is life i promise you something's
gonna happen and if i can get raw for a
second i i'm dealing with what's called
repetitive stress injury from the
entrepreneur hustle in my 20s
i'm coming up on 40 in two more years
you you know the gray beard is fresh i
grew the beard and someone said wow sean
you look five years older i was like
thanks so much
listen
i have some health challenges and if it
wasn't for the think media team i'd be
in a squeezed spot right now
but it reminds me of a verse in
ecclesiastes that said if if one person
is alone and they fall down there's no
one there to help you up but if two are
together
two are built for battle three is even
better
you might not have a team today friend
you might not build the team even in the
next year or two but what's your vision
do you have a vision for it and then are
you thinking about working towards that
every single day i want to encourage you
go and buy chris's book right now not
because uh it's my amazon affiliate link
in the description and i'm going to get
17 cents off of the you know 13 book
sale if you buy the ebook i'm going to
get 11 cents not because those book
sales even really move his income
significantly he's got multiple big
businesses because
by immersing yourself in content this
was just one training by getting the
audiobook and thinking about it and
learning and absorbing it and reading
the book and reading the e-book by even
just getting the book and putting it on
your shelf
by just having the books out i got a
book on take the day off like
you know i why even read that i know
what the book is about it's about taking
you know it's a good book but you know
what i mean a lot of times in the in
just in the title
i want you actually to get the physical
book as just a reminder that i'm going
to take this journey to building a staff
i'm going to take this journey to even
if you end up working with local people
to also adding virtual staff for certain
tasks for certain things for certain
roles
and you don't know what the future is
going to hold and it's going to come
with challenges maybe seasons where you
you get more tired or you need to deal
with a parent who's at a transitioning
stay stage in their legacy years
and it's taking your time and you want
to be there for your loved ones build
the team today you may not even need it
today although you do need it today
build the team today because it's really
going to set you up for tomorrow and so
check out resources in the description
down below inner circle if you've got a
question put four question marks before
and after your question we're going to
be continuing the stream over in the
facebook group and so drop your
questions right now and uh we'll see you
there with chris in just a second and
think media podcast i just want to thank
you so much for being a part of this
training if you want more information
about inner circle that's in the
description down below as well as all of
chris's resources lean in this very
training today could be a moment that
actually changes in fact it will change
the trajectory of your business in your
future if we put it into action so smash
the like button if you got value today
thank you so much for being a part of
this training and click or tap the
screen and we'll see in another video
here on the think media podcast channel